Establishing a mood from the get-go is monumentally
important for a movie, especially for films
of the horror-thriller genre.
A movie's first few scenes can either strike
an audience with terror, or signal yawns to
come … which is particularly scary for horror
fans.
In the case of these freaky flicks, the first
ten minutes are terrifying for all the right
reasons.
A Nightmare on Elm Street
The opening credits for Wes Craven's A Nightmare
on Elm Street introduce Freddie Krueger without
showing his burn-damaged face, as he puts
together his terrifying claw in his boiler
room.
Once his blades are ready, we meet victim
number one.
Tina is a pajama-clad blonde who finds herself
running down the halls of his leaky lair,
all while Krueger cackles at the uselessness
of her escape attempt.
Just as she's about to eat it at the hands
of his new weapon, she awakens to realize
it's all just a dream.
Judging by the slash marks on her gown, though,
we already know in the film's first few moments
that it's much worse than some normal nightmare.
Scream
The opening scene from Scream was an instant
horror favorite, and for good reason.
Casey Becker is your everyday teen girl, cooking
up some popcorn in her home alone, while her
parents are out on a date.
She gets a call from an apparent prankster
who wants to talk about scary movies, and
Casey thinks it's all just fun and games and
plays along…
"Do you like scary movies?"
"Uh huh."
But then the conversation starts to turn dark.
She quickly begins to realize this isn't a
joke, especially once the caller reveals he's
abducted her boyfriend, Steve, and bound him
on her back deck.
Her fight-or-flight response kicks in, but
the latter option isn't available because
the masked boogeyman has gone from lurking
outside to inside.
The villain's speed and ability to predict
her every move, courtesy of the house's open
window scheme, is absolutely crippling.
Making things worse, when the killer finally
strikes, Casey's parents have come back home,
but she can't scream loud enough for anyone
to help her.
"Mom!"
Now, who hasn't had that nightmare before?
Jaws
All Chrissi wanted to do was take a little
night swim with the cute guy she met at a
party.
While she's practically a fish in the moonlit
water, the dude isn't so convinced he's capable
of swimming.
He's pretty drunk, after all, so Chrissie
goes it alone…and gets about halfway to
a buoy before that ominous cello music kicks
in.
Chrissie is all smiles in the dark until something
starts to pull her under.
She's left thrashing and begging for help,
but her wannabe boyfriend is unaware on the
beach.
Desperate, she tries to cling to the buoy,
but she knows she's done for.
"Oh my God, I'm gonna die!"
The shark drags her down and makes a meal
of the poor girl.
Meanwhile, Mr. Helpful is still over there,
drunkenly murmuring to himself on the sand.
Talk about a beach bum.
The Ring
When we first meet Katie and Becca, they're
blabbering about the woes of modern tech,
but one of them is harboring a very dark secret.
It's not the "electrorays" that pose a threat
to the girls -- it's the fabled video tape
Katie has watched that's said to kill anyone
who watches it a week later.
Somehow, she's not bothered by the ominous
warning label that was attached to the tape
or the fact that she received a frightening
phone call soon after her screening of it.
She even fake chokes to show just how unscared
she is.
But her playfulness comes to a halt once things
around the house start turning themselves
on and off and everything's soaking wet all
of a sudden.
When she goes to find Becca, she discovers
the video is playing in her room, and she
gasps as her face turns to stone.
If you've been hesitant to chuck that old
VCR, well, this might change your mind.
Final Destination
The first scene in Final Destination set the
shock value bar pretty high for the films
to follow.
In the beginning, we meet Alex, a high school
student who's boarding Flight 180 with his
school pals.
They're excited for their field trip to Paris,
until all hell breaks loose and the plane
starts to fall apart mid-air, killing some
of the passengers in grisly ways before it
explodes and takes the rest.
Then all of a sudden, Alex wakes up in a cold
sweat and realizes it was just a dream.
He's convinced this is some kind of premonition
that everyone needs to heed.
But after screaming his warnings to the rest
of the passengers, Alex is booted from the
plane, along with a few unhappy tagalongs.
The group is also made to wait in the airport
as the plane takes off for the excursion of
a lifetime, but then Alex's vision comes true
as the plane blows up.
After the first film, the sequels tried to
follow that explosive formula, with a massive
highway pile-up, a roller coaster ride gone
wrong, a race car demolition derby, and a
devastating bridge collapse.
So, if you want to see some movies that are
frontloaded with massive intensity, the Final
Destination movies are your, well, final destination.
Night of the Living Dead
In the introduction to George Romero's seminal
zombie flick, we meet Johnny and Barbra, a
pair of siblings who've trekked out to put
a wreath on their dad's grave.
Due to technical problems with their radio,
they don't hear the warning that's being broadcast
about what they're about to encounter in the
cemetery.
While Barb's paying her respects, Johnny notices
a weird man walking through the graveyard
and makes light of the arrival.
"They're coming for you, Barbara."
Little does he know, his joke has just set
the tone for everything that's about to happen.
Barb tries to pass the stranger, but he reaches
out and grabs her, so Johnny jumps to his
sister's defense, but he's knocked out cold
while trying to wrestle the man to the ground.
Terrified, Barbra kicks off her shoes and
runs away to lock herself inside her car.
The walker doesn't suffer windows, though,
so Barbra releases the parking brake, hoping
she can roll away to safety.
But a tree stops her progress, forcing her
to flee on foot.
When she enters an abandoned farmhouse that
seems relatively safe, it's only the beginning
of her bout with this deadly humanoid thing…and
many others to come.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!